When I was a kid, I always wanted to be a marine biologist,...
...and I was the person that would always be spouting off random facts...
...like, "Did you know a blue whale can be 110 feet long,"...
...just to people I didn't even know.
And I always felt that there's something that we can learn from them.
What really attracted me to the program...
...was the idea that I would be able to still do science.
My role is a volunteer citizen scientist.
What I do is I fly my drones in the beaches on the California coast...
...to help map and determine the effects of El Nino.
This year, California is experiencing a sort of unprecedented El Nino event.
We've got very extreme weather...
...and given how strong it is gives us a sort of crystal ball...
...about what sea level rise and what climate change is gonna look like...
...in the future along the California coast.
Using phones or drones, UAVs, to document that change...
...would be a good way to do that.
So, we've asked people to take photos of events,...
...where there's been real high water along the coast...
...or water that's been overtopping dunes or inundating coastal areas.
Another big reason that I really wanted to be involved...
...was that there's a lot of publicity about drones,...
...and a lot of it isn't necessarily good.
There's a lot that drones can do that are good for the community...
...and for the world, and it's just getting the word out there.